Hello,
and welcome
to the next workshop
in the complete guide to Teleport course.
Today,
we are gonna be taking a look at
a really cool feature of Teleport, which allows
you to commoditize the access
to your databases.
Today, we will be using a Postgres
through the Teleport system.
We are going to be doing another database
access workshop next week on MongoDB.
So we'll be aiming to cover Postgres and
Mongo in a week to show you this
just amazing feature of Teleport.
Database access is something that is notoriously
tricky
to do in a safe and secure way,
you know, through bastion boxes,
the key management,
even speaking and talking about passwords over the
phone. We do some weird and wonderful things
in the IT community when it comes to
database access.
From having our GUI clients have red colored
backgrounds and themes to indicate that we're on
production, and maybe we wanna think about our
commands a little bit more.
We have a
GitHub repository
for all of the workshops that we have
as
part of this course.
So, let me get my screen shared.
You
will find it at Rawkode Academy,
which is the organization on GitHub.
And then there is a repository called courses.
We have our first low.
Hey, Russell. Thank you for joining us.
So you can find this database access here.
I think this is part seven, to be
honest, I've gotten a little bit confused about
the order I planned on doing this in,
just because of my father in law's funeral
at the end of last year, I'm currently
trying to sell my house and move house
and of course, the festive and new year
period. So my head is a bit scattered,
but maybe seven, I may change out there.
However, there are a few prerequisites
that are required if you wish to follow
along or do this in your own time,
depending on if you're watching it right now
and you can actually say hello or whether
you're doing this in the future.
You will require a running and working Teleport.
I'm doing things a little bit different today.
Normally,
I would run my own Teleport.
Typically, I spin it up on a cloud
provider of choice, throw a DNS name on
it, usually
something.
Rokode.live,
and I use that.
However, I decided today to try and make
my life a little bit easier,
and I'm using Teleport Cloud.
So I get a nice DNS name of
Rawkode.teleportsh
and
I get the latest and greatest version of
Teleport.
So let's see how this goes, right? Of
course, when they change things on this, nothing
ever goes wrong, right?
So I don't need to worry about
running and working Teleport. I've let Intelliport do
that all for me. Now, it's not free.
I'm on a fourteen day trial. I'll see
how I like it. But so far, it
seems pretty cool.
We need a running and working Postgres.
Okay. So let's do that together.
I
have a virtual machine running on Civo cloud
and
I have a terminal.
Add.
Add a terminal, which is nicely timed out
on me. Let's see if I can pop
that back open.
Rawkode.
Well, I fixed this. We have a hello
from Jeffrey. Hey, Jeffrey. How's it going?
Thank you for joining me for this live
workshop where only good, happy things happen and
nothing bad ever happens.
The IP address is wrong here. So my
auto complete didn't close to the latest one.
This one has now closed, but here I
am. So this is just a
Let me just pull this over here.
This is one of Siebel's large boxes,
which is four CPUs and eight gig of
RAM coming from a bare metal world.
I'm not inclined to call that large, however.
I guess in a virtual world, it is
quite chunky.
I've run an apt update and, you know,
Postgres is ubiquitous. This is why I started
with the database access for Postgres because
an app installed PostgresQL is always gonna work
unless it fails, in which case it's probably
DNS installed Postgres. You know, there's not a
lot of variation here. Not gonna be difficult
to get this right.
Putting a lot of confidence there myself, but,
and Postgres is, I see no issue, it's
on every operating system.
That red line has been worried already.
I'm on a bint too.
You're supposed to be good at this.
We'll let it finish before I start debugging.
Data's down.
Well, mean, it's definitely not what I was
expecting.
But
app is having a moment. So let's
just give it a second.
This is why I choose Postgres. It's ubiquitous.
Every operating system has it and it fails.
I wonder if this is the post installation
step,
which is now not gonna complete because of
that one little red line.
Hello, Omar. Thank you for joining this very
special edition of clustered butler posters.
Let's see what the error was.
This is this is this is taking too
long for me. I don't feel like I'm
being impatient. I think this is
control c doesn't work, by the way.
We're just gonna keep opening terminals.
Okay. What we got? Database system is ready
to accept connections.
Peer authentication field for user Postgres. Okay, that
I can fix that. Not fussed. Oh,
maybe I was being impatient.
And now that my control C has come
through as it was processing the triggers on
the libc bend. So let's just make sure
it's happy. Right, okay. So the Pure authentication
failed for Postgres.
I
want to be able to debug
things as I go along.
And so I need to be able to
connect to Postgres. So I am going to
do a Postgres
pghba,
and I'm gonna change local all Postgres to
trust.
This will keep my life easier. Of course,
it does mean that any local user on
machine can connect, but then as I have
access to this machine, I've got bigger problems.
So,
before we start,
and this should allow me to do the
SQL user,
Postgres.
Tada.
That's about what we want. So now we
have a working Postgres.
So,
done. The next thing that we need is
a Teleport CLI authenticated.
So at the moment,
I'm not gonna be able to do app
install Teleport.
However, it is a single
well, I know it's a single line. It's
a couple of lanes, but it's particular.
It's pretty simple.
So we just quickly grab this and then
we'll talk about the tasks that we're gonna
accomplish on today's workshop. Well, this quickly runs.
The curl.
Oh, yeah, the curl worked.
We'll do apt install.
Js Teleport.
And that should just do its thing.
I'll authenticate with that in just a second.
So, there are a few different stages to
exposing your databases through the Teleport system.
First thing we need to do, and I
think we
covered this on application access, is that Teleport
is broken down into a few components.
There's like the Teleport server,
which runs, typically runs the off server
and the SSH server,
and everything else is kind of opt in
after that, the proxy server, the app server,
the DB servers, etcetera.
In order for us to run a TeleportDB
proxy DB server next to our Postgres server,
you know, we don't probably want these to
be far apart because then we'd be exposing
our Postgres over the big bad internet.
Then we just need to be able to
generate a token that speaks to the Teleport
server and says, hey, I want a token
that's gonna allow me to expose a database
on this machine. So we're gonna generate one
of those.
We then have to generate certificates. This only
works with x five zero nine TLS
mutual authentication on the client side. So we
have to generate those certificates, Teleport will do
that for us,
and configure Postgres to accept that as a
means of authentication.
Once that's configured, we need to tweak the
roles a little bit just to allow my
user and the Teleport system to be able
to access this database system.
And
something I found out when I was trialing
this workshop is that Teleport Cloud just needs
to do one extra little step because I
don't control the Teleport server component,
but we do have to modify a role
to allow impersonation of the DB persona.
We then run our Teleport DB proxy, and
then we'll start interacting with it. We'll list
available databases,
we'll log into Postgres and connect to Postgres.
And then just at the end,
to show you how this works with your
standard tooling, I'll show you how to connect
with just PSQL
using a Postgres GUI.
So we should be able to do this
and just under the hour, at least my
tests left it that way. I've included all
of the answers, so you don't really need
to sit and listen to me if you
don't want to, but of course I do
appreciate the company.
And you
should be fine to run to the diskette.
It should just work
minus any little random things.
And hopefully that was enough waffle for Teleport
to be installed.
So if I run TSH
status
status.
That duration is on there. I cannot automate
it crazy, but we
don't have any credentials. We're not authenticated against
the Teleport server.
So we're going to do
TSH
login
and we have to provide the proxy server,
which for me will be Rawkode.
Teleport SSH on port four forty three.
I'm not rich.
So, that'll be user.
Like so.
Alright.
Now I need my password.
Password.
OTP.
Fingers crossed.
And good. Yep. There we go. So now
I'm authenticated against my
Teleport Cloud
instance.
Magic.
Hey, Mozz, thanks for joining us.
Okay.
So we can see now
that I have a TSH status, which is
gonna be the same output.
I have my Postgres
running and we tested the work. We connected
to it by enabling the trust and
the Teleport is already proven. So the first
thing we need to do
is
it's not formatted correctly. I'll fix that there.
It's use T control, Teleport Control,
to generate a new token of type database.
Now this just means
that
when a Teleport,
it's not a server, what is that? A
Teleport
proxy, I think that might be it.
edge server, DB server. I need to confirm
the lingo there. But when this Teleport instance
that we are gonna run locally
can only register
the database. It only has access to register
databases on the server. We don't want it
to be able to do anything else. Like,
we don't want it to allow people to
connect their own servers to our Teleport, or
I suppose their own applications or anything like
could be
used and abused.
So, we're gonna run Teleport Control tokens add
type DB,
and this should
just
spit out
this nice little helper command,
which tells us how to start a TeleportDB
proxy.
The command line arguments we need, it's got
the token here that we just generated as
well as the CA pin so that we
can always guarantee and confirm that we are
speaking to the correct Teleport server.
It has the auth server dropped in here,
which we already knew, and then we have
the name, the protocol, the URI.
So I'm just gonna keep this,
create
bb proxy,
and just dump this into here so we
can use it later.
Excel.
I believe we can do,
am I getting too confident?
Yeah, there we go. TCTR. I can never
remember what's Teleport Control and what's TSH.
Tokens,
learn to spell.
Because LSLX flow and
we should see
our DB. Well, that proxy one. I probably
shouldn't show you that.
I'm sure it's okay.
Here is our DB token. So, if you
ever need to get that back, you can
use Teleport Control Tokens l s. And I'll
clear my screen just in case, even though
you can write it and pause it. But
still, it makes me feel better.
Alright. Thank you, generate token. We are done.
And, obviously, I just clicked on the answer
there. The documentation is is great. You can
come in to here and go to database.
There we go. Database access was self hosted
Postgres.
A lot of these steps are already covered
here.
This is where you find all of your
answers.
So we've got a question from Moz
asking, is it possible to run Teleport DB
proxy as a daemon? Yeah, totally. 100%
you can.
You can create a system new unit file
and manage it anyway you want.
It's just a banging away with some arguments.
So whatever your supervisor system is, feel free
to take it and run it that way.
Of course, that is a much preferred way,
just not something I'm gonna be doing today,
but you can totally do it.
And there's this increment here. Cool.
So, the next step is we wanna be
able to generate the certificates for Postgres
to run-in TLS mode.
So, we'll just pop open this answer
and copy this and we'll run through each
of these things here.
So this is a Teleport Control off SANE.
This is just gonna speak to the Teleport
server and say that we want to be
able to,
you know,
provision some certificates that can authenticate against the
server.
The format here is because we're very specifically
allowing access to the databases, but we have
format DB.
We need to provide the host. So this
is where is my Postgres server.
I'm going to use localhost today because I'm
running Postgres on the same machine that I
am running my DB proxy.
We can pass dash dash out. This just
tells it
what prefix to use for the file names.
So you're gonna get like a
server dot CRT, a server dot PEM, a
server
I'm sure there's one more.
And this is just what they are. So
we will just call this server.
And we get these attempts to leverage how
long should these certificates live.
So this should finish.
And, you know, Teleport,
you know, as I was working through this
and trying to see how to get this
working, there was one thing that tripped me
up and we can talk about that later.
But
Teleport
is very handily just giving you everything that
you need along the way. You know, we
created the DB token and it's like, Hey,
you're gonna wanna run a DB proxy here's
the command.
Like, this is, it's just, it's almost too
easy to get this, you know, to get
this effect, to get this access that I
want. And I really appreciate that
from the Teleport team.
So, we've got our CA file, our key,
and our certificate.
It has given us the exact thing that
we need to copy into the Postgres configuration
to make that work.
And if we run ALS,
we have our files here.
Wonderful. So let's close that.
So,
Postgres doesn't support TLS mode by default. We
do need to configure it. There's a couple
of different steps here.
We need to add, we can just copy
this.
Well, I've not moved them yet.
So we've got slash path to server CRT.
So yeah, do we really wanna leave these
line and slash root? Probably
not.
Postgres makes use of varlib.
Postgres
12 main as a directory with all its
configuration and stuff. It also makes use of
etc.
Postgres
12 main, where it has more configurate Oh,
I guess the varlib is more state than
configuration.
And all the config lists and etc.
I've never really had much of an opinion
on whether sets are
config or state, I feel the line in
the middle.
But for the basis of today, and because
this is how I did it on my
tests,
we're gonna move all of these server files
to the varlab
postgres
12 main.
And if we run our LS again
Oh, wrong LS. I was a bit worried
there.
We
have our server fails. And of course, if
we run that with a dash L,
right? Spot the elephant in the room, we
of course need to change the permissions
on these fails too. Postgres does not run
as a root user,
so it would actually not even be able
to
read those files. So we can do a
change on ownership,
Postgres, Postgres,
Rlib,
Postgres,
12 main,
server star.
I'll run my LS one more time.
And that looks
pretty good. I'm happy with that.
Okay.
Did I copy?
No, I didn't. So we're gonna scroll up
and copy
this.
So we need to add this to our
Postgres
configuration.
Well, main and that lives inside of PostgresQL
dot conf.
We're just gonna jump all the way down
to the bottom. And I'm just gonna save
this quickly so that I can copy
the path for where all the files are.
There we go.
Let's see if I'm
gonna get this right.
Just put this don't allow me to use
arbitrary
splatters.
Let's find that.
Drop this in.
Thank you, Vim. I know a
lot of commands said and such, you can
actually use wherever it doesn't have to be
a slash after like the S at the
start to the substitute.
You can use anything, it just has to
be repeated on the other side. So that's
good.
So we'll configure our SSL cert file, our
SSL key file and our SSL CA file
and turned SSL on.
The real test now would be to save
this
and restart
Postgres.
Okay.
Well, let's use
the control status.
Postgres
exited
ten seconds ago. So I have
broken it.
Okay.
Let's go to the logs and see what
I did.
Oh, it's ready.
Active exited.
I must be reading that wrong.
Oh, postgres.
Yeah. Yeah. It's fine.
System d trying to obviously
confuse and scare me there,
but we're good.
So Mozz asked,
what does the
hash symbol mean on the VUM substitute command?
Yeah. That's a good question. So,
I I would
turn this into like a
VUM session or anything, but let's say we
have hello.
Why is with my typing?
Goodbye.
Thanks.
Alright. The Scottish version.
Is that we can now use
I'm not sure.
It's regex syntax. I'm not sure if it's
specific to them and said that supports the
random delimiter,
but I'm pretty sure it's pretty
common.
So find me,
replace me.
This is
a really standard
search and replace regex.
You do s
and slash.
So I
wish I could tell you that the s
means search or substitute. I think it does,
but I'm not entirely sure.
And then normally with regex, we would do
slash search term slash replace term
slash
and then the g on the end is
for modifiers
to your search and replace.
You can do the G, which is global,
which means replace everything.
You can do I, which is a case
sensitive.
And there is
M for multilane. I can't remember. No. Yeah.
If you're not doing global, there's maybe like
an M which allows you to do multilanes.
There's a whole bunch of modifiers that you
can put on the end.
But
because forward slash is such a common symbol
and like web addresses and code and stuff
like that, You can actually use any delimiter
on the search replace modifiers
that you want
and
it just works.
So as an example here, if we do
s and we're gonna do search, I'll do
it slash, I mean, that's the default term.
We can say hello should be
howdy.
Oh, I didn't do global.
Hello,
howdy.
There we go. Our hello changes to howdy.
But I can do that again and this
time I say how without the slash and
I can use a plus
and do howdy plus
hello
plus g and it still works.
So,
yeah, there you go. It doesn't matter what
the dormer is.
You use whatever works
depending on what you wanna search and what
you wanna replace.
Sweet. Okay.
Oh, yes. So our postgres is working,
which is fantastic.
So let's
jump back to our workshop.
So configure it for TLS mode. I think
we've done this. I'm gonna pop open the
answer, make sure I've not missed anything.
So I say here, yeah, move the start.
So location that Postgres has access to,
this is a solid choice.
Change the ownership,
which it did.
We ran the off sync command.
We added these lanes.
Oh yeah. And one last thing. So this
is in the documentation as well.
Host
SSL
is when you're configuring a server, you can
additionally
modify
the PGHP fail. So this fail is kinda
like, you know, your PAM configuration on a
Linux machine where you configure whether people are
gonna log in with password or just keys.
And then the order and the fail is
the order that the priority exists within the
authentication system.
It's pretty much the exact same for Postgres.
So, we can just copy these two lanes
and put them into our PGHBA.
And this will just tell us that we
allow
when someone connects over SSLTLS
for all user, all databases and all IP
addresses that we allow certificate based authentication.
So we need to make that change. So
we go to etcetera,
Postgres,
12 main,
pg.
And we're gonna stick this right up
here.
So we
prioritize and prepare certificate based authentication. We're gonna
check that first.
Now we do another big scary restart.
I'm
not gonna trust
some of the status.
I will just test.
Still good.
Nice.
So now we have configured
Postgres. Postgres is now ready for us to
start proxying our access through the Teleport system.
Okay, so I'll close these as I go,
so I don't get too confused. I'm easy,
easy confused.
So now we have exercise five and there's
a 5B. 5B,
I'm gonna have to do it because this
is Teleport Cloud. If you're just using Teleport
that you configured yourself, you do not need
to do that step.
So we have to add a role now.
Format is dreadful.
I don't know if had it can't be
because it's a pop down. It's just I've
just messed this up. I will fix all
the formatting.
I mean, in fact, you know what? I'm
gonna view this as raw just for today.
Oh, no. Because then I'll see all my
I'll
I'll pop it open in raw too. There
we go. That's a good idea. And then
I can copy and paste what I
So exercise five, we're
gonna add a rule. Yeah. That's okay.
I never like it's weird and like, you
need the space after the paragraph.
I I could commit it and see, but
it's not important.
Stop following rabbit holes, Dave.
Okay. So
we need to create a role that is
gonna allow
anyone who has that role to be able
to access the databases.
So we have a workshop on
a deep dive into the RBAC system and
Teleport that we'll be covering in a couple
of weeks.
So we'll keep it super professional for today.
But if you have questions, I'm happy to
answer them as we go.
So we're gonna create a roles file. We
paste this in.
We don't need this. So the default are
really Kubernetes manifests,
they'll say here,
kind and version. So this is role V4
with a metadata and the name. The name
is arbitrary.
I can call this
local
post for SQL
access.
And the spec here is that we're gonna
allow
star star all the way down. So anyone
with this role can connect to any database
that is configured and proxy for the Teleport
system.
And I'll never remember to type this. So
let's just call it DB.
We can then apply that. So, you can
use t control dash f, very Kubernetes like
again,
where we just say, hey, go and create
this role for me please.
That's done. We can use
roles ls.
Nope.
Am I wrong?
Thought you could get roles. Alright. Okay. We
can run the get command, which I think
gives you a back of YAML. I guess
that's good enough for today.
And we can see all the roles in
the system.
Does it work if No. It doesn't work.
Not sure why you can't
roles list.
You can users list.
Not a big deal.
Okay. So we
The Mars has jumped in the comments saying
he can teleport control DB get rules.
No, because this rule isn't actually specific
to
databases. This is a general teleport rule that
works
across app proxy and database proxy and server
management, etcetera.
But I will I'll I'll try it.
No.
Just dbls. Yeah.
To be honest, the problem is just not
implemented rules ls.
Not a big deal. We don't use it
for today anyway.
You can always do
p control,
get roles,
save that YAML file and then create apply
over the top of it. So if you
don't need to change the roles, that's just
how you would do it. Not being able
to list them on the end of world,
let's get it. Keep moving.
What we do need to do is we
can use users
l s
to see me.
Yep. There we go. I don't have
this rule.
So we can do t control,
get
users,
users dot YAML,
and then modify
the YAML,
go to roles,
and I just jumped straight in here, like
an absolute wild card and save the YAML
and then create apply over the top. Now
it allows me to modify my user.
There is a nicer way,
but I can never remember what it is.
What's the subcommand on users?
Not reset. That's like a user
mod command. Maybe it's in my my cheat
sheet.
Oh,
okay. You can just do that. So I
could have done use add
roles.
Oh, but I have to specify all the
Oh yeah. I think that's gonna overrate it
completely. Let's try it. Right? I like to
break things.
Access.
What are the roles that I have?
An order.
Audit r
David
Rawkode.
So was that removed DB? We're about to
find out.
Oh, no. Sorry. Okay. So that's just for
adding new users. Alright. Okay. So, maybe the
only way to edit is just through the
get users, modify the YAML, chuck it back
in. Something I'd appreciate,
we're using Teleport Cloud. I had never noticed
this on open source, but maybe, I don't
know if it's different is that you can
modify myself from here.
Don't want DB. Well, get myself DB.
I haven't seen this in the open source
one. I don't know if it's coming or
if it's just on cloud or enterprise,
but I thought that was quite a new
feature. You can also modify the rules themselves
too.
Excuse me.
And that's dropped straight into your YAML thing.
There you go.
And they list them here. Maybe there's a
secret API for getting the rules.
So we have a question from Oz.
The access rule also has DB names and
DB users. Does that override your rule?
No, they're merged.
So it's not overwritten
in any way, they're just merged.
So it has DB labels, but not DB
names and DB users.
So you would still need
to give yourself a database role with star
star across the board.
At least I believe that's my answer. That's
how I think it works.
One more question from Russell.
Does that UI show which users are assigned
to the role?
No,
but here you can see them on this
list here.
That's a wee bit small, isn't it? You
can see the roles a user has here,
but there's no user list on the corresponding
role
thing.
So, you can't see the users from here.
Something I did notice during my testing is
that now that I have a saying, I
bet this works now, that's gonna be annoying
me. If I try and delete the database
rule, it will tell me that a user
has it.
Yeah. Because
it's still used by user, so you can't
do it.
Another thing that wasted
a substantial
amount of
my time during the testing here is that
your roles,
if you change your roles, you need to
log out and log back into the system.
So,
search status,
you'll see here that even though I now
have the database role,
I don't have
listed locally. And when I try to execute
any of
the
database commands to connect to the database, etcetera,
they failed with an access denied. And it's
just because the token
that I got when I signed in,
obviously, you know, if you're familiar with JSON
web tokens, they have like the subject and
they have the capabilities all embedded in HMAC
consent.
And so you have to log out and
log back in to refresh that.
We got another question
from Russell.
Can you filter
the user screen by role?
Let's find out.
Yes.
Because when I say DB, I don't disappear.
So
yes, you can filter by
editor.
Yeah.
So it appear you can type in a
role name and it will filter the users.
Not the most intuitive search bar, like whether
I knew I could do that, but, you
know, trial and error, that's how we do
things.
All right, let's get back on track. So
we have created our database role, which is
star star across the board.
Let's take a look at that one more
time.
So
labels, names, and users, star slash star. So
anyone with that role can speak to any
database that is proxied by Teleport system.
I don't have that role yet.
I'll need to log out and log back
in, but we'll I wonder if there's a
way for me to refresh that.
Well, let's not get a rabbit hole. I've
got twenty three minutes left. Okay. So let's
carry on. If you have any more questions,
keep them coming.
So we created the role, we modified our
user, I'll add the get users, edit, apply
thing here, just for anyone as using self
hosted. You
may have to be able to just create
a new user. Of course, I could just
have created a new user too called my
special DB user,
but that's not we'll
forget I said that. Okay. On Teleport Cloud,
I did find that we needed to add
this impersonate
capability.
So we're going to use the get rules,
edit rules, create rules trick at the to
add this to our DB rule.
So get
rules.
Roles.
Yaml.
This access.
Order.
D b.
Allow.
Delete,
boom, boom.
Yep. That's it. So everyone with this rule
can impersonate, gives us some rules. Weird though
that
this is also on the
access one.
Yeah. Impersonate
here.
But I'm pretty sure it had an error
when I didn't add it to the DB
one. So
just when in doubt, do it twice.
And we'll apply that.
There's a question from Russell that I can
definitely
guess based on what I've seen
during my Teleport workshops. So Russell is asking,
if you also have the role privileges, does
it apply straight away? I could you grab
start to a role you already have and
suddenly get full access?
Yes.
Because
the only thing my authenticated token contains is
the roles that I have and not the
capabilities of that role. So, if I can
speak to the server with my JSON web
token saying here, can I look at my
JSON web token?
Key.
Should I be putting this over here? This
is my Teleport load account.
For once in my life, I'm adding on
the state of caution.
I'm gonna look at it locally first
because I'm worried.
Yeah. Great advice, Russell. Don't do it.
So
I'm just pulling up locally. I wanna
Yeah. I can't share that.
Okay.
It's not adjacent web token, which I didn't
know either. It's the actual x5.1 language, I
guess makes sense. But the roles are, will
be same than that rather
than the capability. So I guess if we
have time at the end, we'll try it.
We'll remove all of my roles,
bar the DB one and incrementally add new
functionality to it and see if things work.
But I suspect it will.
Right.
Let's get back on track.
So now that we have added the impersonate
thing, which is just a cloud thing, don't
worry about it for self hosted, we wanna
be able to run this proxy. Now we
format is annoying.
We saved this command
and
a local file, didn't we?
Yep. Create DB proxy. So let's fill this
out.
So we have a token. We've got the
pen.
We call this my Postgres,
the protocol is
Postgres
and it is available on local host five
forty three.
Sure.
We can make this executable
and away we go.
So we can see here that is joining
our secure cluster.
Things are working. It seems to be happy
and the database service has been successfully started.
So let's pop open one more terminal
and get back to where we were.
Perfect.
I should still have my status.
While this is done is because we've had
this database proxy run on the machine and
register itself is that we're now in a
position where if we pop over to databases,
we will see that we have a self
hosted post GRES cluster
and click connect, that gives you all the
commands that you need to be able to
try and interact with this.
Yeah, and there's some documentation for the GUI
stuff, but I'll show you that in a
minute.
So we have our app proxy.
Done.
Now we want to list the available databases.
I already mentioned this command. You can run
DBLS,
so you can do everything from the command
line that we can do from the gray.
I can see here that I have a
Postgres, but I'm not connected to it. There's
no information here. I don't give a description
or label that same, but we're not connected.
And the next task as well,
log in and connect to it.
So we can do a TSH
DB
log in and then we look at the
parameters here. We have to tell the database,
which will just be Postgres for me.
But when we log in, we can also
specify the database user and database name
that we wanna be able to access through
that session. So we can do a TSH
DB login DB user, Postgres
DB
name,
Postgres.
Like so.
And Postgres is the DB name.
Let's see if that works.
Our connection information for database Postgres has been
saved.
So let's try
connect Postgres
like it suggests.
And we get access denied.
So this is how
I discovered
that your roles
yeah. You need to say no and load
back in for your roles.
And the way that I discovered that,
there's nothing in the logs here.
I enabled
session logging on Postgres. I wasn't seeing any
connection. I was
pulling my hair out mad,
but there's a command.
We can add a flag
debug
to our proxy and we're gonna get a
whole lot more logs. Hopefully nothing
scary that I should be sharing with the
world.
But if we run this again, we'll see
the exact error message that finally
led me to work out what the hell
is going on.
Let's try that connect again.
There we go.
That is the culprit there.
So access to DB Postgres denied,
no allow rule matched, rule access matches, rule
editor matches,
rule other matches,
rule default matches, no role DB.
And that's when I finally clicked.
The frustrating thing about that is I didn't
really get that information from the activity thing.
So we come to the auto log. You
can actually see when people are trying to
use your databases to Teleport. Again, very, very
cool.
To me,
it just looks like it's a Postgres that
are denying me. And I was jumping through
lots of hoops of Postgres and checking that
host SSL and the HBA configuration and all
this stuff. And all you need to do
is log out. That's it. So
we'll just leave that in debug mode, not
the underworld.
We'll log out.
We will log in,
proxy,
Rawkode
Teleport,
SH four four three user.
And
Teleport
Cloud.
Password.
OTP.
And now you'll see we have our database
role available.
And that just means that if I do
a connect to Postgres, we should land an
AP SQL prompt.
Hey, that's
all right.
So the problem is
I need to log in again.
I
guess it's telling me I can use the
DB Gazerna Connect, but I'm pretty sure
that should do it. So when I logged
out of TSH and logged back in, I
think what happened is the TSH DB connect
was
I think it did a login for me,
but without the DB user and DB
name parameters.
So let's try
and see if that changes anything here.
Yeah. So you can see now when I
do the list, I don't know the connect
would do the login for me. There you
go. We can see that we've now configured
it as Postgres Postgres. So I should be
able to just do connect now and it
should just work without any additional parameters.
It's doing the dance. There we go. And
we now have access to Postgres
through Teleport.
Awesome.
That's cool.
So a couple of questions from Moz there.
I missed
did you enable the DB proxies to use
SSL to connect with the Postgres DB? The
proxy only
will communicate through TLS mutual authentication.
So it doesn't need to configure it. It's
just the way that it works.
The commands
that we use
Yeah. You don't need to configure that. It
just works.
Where's my mess?
And most tell me, yes, I will have
to log in again. Yep.
Cool that the connect does do
the
login for you. So I guess it's probably
just a bit easier to do connect
DB user,
blah, blah, blah.
Yeah, log in first. Be nice and explicit.
All right, we've got ten minutes left. Let's
take a look at our audit log.
We have our database session ended.
Look at this, is this not just the
coolest thing ever, right? Our database session was
started.
So we can see what time I started
my session,
the user,
we can pop open the queries.
So, you know, I could hook, I would
love to hook all of this up to
influx DB,
low key, and just
analyze queries and see what's going on.
It's just practical.
And we can see that I ran a
select from the catalog, although I used the
alias
backslash L.
What does it upload the session?
I don't think so.
Record the session has been uploaded.
Oh, yeah. Okay. So something Teleport Cloud does
is work through a session recording to Amazon
s three
for you.
Don't know why it doesn't show here.
Wonder if there's a small delay on picking
that up. Not a big deal. But I'm
assuming I can replay that, which is nice.
I didn't know that.
So we'll come back here and
we got two tasks to finish just to
end this with a bit of fun.
So we logged in,
command is there. We connected, command is there.
There's a really
cool thing you can use instead of using
a DB login and connect, you can actually
ask for a config, which will allow you
to use the native tooling.
So we can do DB
config postgres.
I'm
sure there was another
thing you could do.
Yeah. Env.
There we go.
This will actually drop out something I can
then evaluate in my shell and get a
whole bunch of the PSQL things that I
need to connect.
So let's try it that way. That's not
in my
gate, but I'm gonna add it because it's
too cool.
So let's do
pb env equals
to res
eval.
Make sure that worked.
Mhmm.
So I just did that.
Yeah. See, it's going through. We can see
the logs that's set in the proxy.
And there I am.
It's an SSL connection. So typically when I
would run PSQL,
that's just gonna use the daemon approach
and log in. But the fact that we
can do the DBN and go through the
secure way, which is also recorded, that's really
cool. So as a Postgres operator administrator,
I would
blanket just block
any
access that rely on our proxy
and set authentication.
That's awesome. I love that too.
So, Mozz
asked,
would I please share some details on how
to enable session recording on Teleport eight? You
tried just to do it, it wasn't working.
Feel free to post the error message that
you got into the Discord channel. I'll be
sure to take a look at it. And
I'll do some tests tomorrow as well and
make sure it's still working for me. I
didn't notice any problems on my local setup,
but we'll work it out. Just drop it
into the Discord and I'll get you some
help.
Alright. So, what about the GUI? So, I'm
gonna jump onto
my local machine.
I don't have the rule.
I'm gonna have to log out.
Again,
Password again.
OTP.
So this is cool. And as I send
the answer here, but you can use the
proxy command
to get a
Oh, wow.
There we go.
Teleport
is watching. Hey, Teleport.
Teleport says,
you may want to check the RBAC for
access.
Yeah. So
Moz, I believe that's the relation
to your question.
Okay. So,
got a few minutes left. So we wanna
use the GUI. So there is a TSH
proxy command
where we can run a proxy to the
DB
and to Postgres.
And that's just I didn't log in. Didn't
log in, not this thing.
Log in Postgres DB
user
Postgres DB name Postgres.
I guess this has to go
yeah.
The database name on the end.
This should log me in and then I
should be able to create that proxy, which
will allow me to use a GUI client,
which, you know,
maybe a lot nicer
than learn how to PSQL command.
So it runs a proxy on a port
as port number changes every time. So you
do need to copy this.
I don't think Teleport have a Discord channel.
They have a Slack.
Sorry, Moz is in the comments. Can you
please share your So my Discord is Rawkode.chat
and the Teleport Slack, I believe is goteleport.com/slack.
Yeah, there we go. Was trying to log
me in, but yeah, so goteleport.com/slack
and lots of really helpful people in there
as well.
Okay, so we've ran our TSH DB proxy
postgres. We've got this port number and IP
address, just local host, and then we've got
a whole bunch of files that we can
configure with our client.
So far today, I'm gonna use Beekeeper studio.
I thought it looked good.
That was my reason for picking it. I
thought it was the nicest looking of the
clients I was playing with earlier.
So we're gonna connect to Postgres,
local host.
We drop the port and
Oh, it's not letting on the thing, but
there we go. Five, was it 55544?
Yeah, 55544.
We have to enable
SSL and
then we can hook up these files.
So we need our CA cert,
which is certs. Pen,
our certificate,
which is, you know, I'm just reading this
from this line on the bottom of my
terminal here. The certificate
is the Postgres X509,
which is in this directory.
And we need the key file, which is
just my
x five one nine identity key.
So that will be here.
And we're going to connect as Postgres.
We don't need the password
to the Postgres
database.
Attest.
Moment of truth.
Longer is better, right? I mean,
yeah, that's worked. And
we hit connect.
Look at that.
We're in.
We can see on the left, it's finding
tables. We'll give that just a few seconds.
We've got the query where I can type
something here.
You know, can just select star
from
information
schema.
Nope.
That's my all complete. I can't do this
on my own.
P g
catalog.
I
can't remember.
Maybe that's pulling out
millions of stuff. Let's cancel. Oh no, wasn't
too bad. But we can just pop around
and take a look
at the schema.
I thought that was really cool. I haven't
used this client an awful lot, but I
thought it was a nice looking native black
client. So that's what we went with for
today.
I'm gonna close that. I'm gonna close this
and this
head back to here. And we have completed
all the tasks in today's workshop with a
record
just under two minutes left to go. I'm
gonna pop back over
here. If you have any questions, drop them
into the chat and I'll tackle them before
we wrap up for today's session.
But we'll be back on
Monday
at 12:30
UTC,
where we are doing
MongoDB.
Let me take a look at my channel.
Oh, no. Monday is deploying Teleport on Kubernetes.
There we go. And then next this time
next week, we'll be doing MongoDB.
There we go. I may swap them. Just
so we're doing the database ones back to
back.
We'll do the Kubernetes one at the end
of week. We'll see. I'll think about it.
All right. So there haven't been any questions.
Ma says, this is awesome. You're right. This
is a really cool feature. I love to
do the best access.
I love as I was typing Teleport commands
that the output was then guiding me on
the next step and helping me get forward.
I like it when tools really just kind
of try to make good life easier. So
thanks and props to the Teleport team.
All right. Let's call that a wrap. Thanks
for joining me today. Some great questions. I
hope you like this feature. Let me know
how you get on and
have a wonderful weekend. Goodbye all.